well parasites are a huge menace to any
free living organism for one thing
they're just a whole bunch of them
they're a lot more of those parasites
than there are of us so perhaps four
five six seven parasites for every free
living species that's one estimate I've
seen although I bet there's a lot more
and so these things these parasites
they're trying to use us and other hosts
to make more copies of themselves that's
what they do and in the process we can
get pretty sick or die so any kind of
mutation that might give us a little bit
of resistance might be able to let us
evade these parasites it's going to be
incredibly valuable it's going to be
strongly favored by natural selection
and so you can see the effect of
parasites on us in lots of different
ways I mean you can just go through the
genome the human genome and and see that
the fingerprints of parasites there
they're all over the place there they
have shaped genes that make our immune
system better able to recognize certain
kinds of parasites for example they have
in some parts of the world they have
made people resistant to malaria by
making their blood cells harder for the
malaria parasite to invade and on the
other hand we have also kind of reached
kind of an uneasy kind of a date on with
with some parasites as well if you go to
a jungle and look at the people who live
there and this can be in the jungle to
Venezuela or in central Africa or
what-have-you places far from medical
care people are loaded with parasites
particularly intestinal worms but it
generally doesn't harm their help all
that much and what's also interesting is
that
people in these parts of world also
don't have a lot of allergies whereas if
you were to go to a city in Venezuela
for example you would find people who
have very few of these parasites but
have lots of allergies and other kind of
autoimmune disorders so there is a
theory that over the past century we we
have we have rid ourselves a lot of
these nasty parasites I mean nobody
wants hookworm but the problem is that
our immune systems had evolved to be in
a kind of a balance with these parasites
so they sort of hold them in check but
they would not attack them too severely
and it appears that that our immune
systems have to learn to find this
balance but if we live a life that is in
a sense to clean we can't our bodies
don't learn that balance and so we get
thrown off and we might attack some
meaningless thing like a piece of cat
dander or a piece of mold we and we
totally overreact because our immune
systems haven't been trained to
basically calm down so so parasites have
have affecting affected us on on all
sorts of different levels
now if you have parasite very often you
don't just want to make your host sick
you actually have other things in mind
so for example there is a fungus that
lives inside of ants called cordyceps
now the fungus has to get from one ant
to the next and what it does is it it's
going to shower its spores down on
healthy ants well what that means is
that it's got to get up above those ants
so how does it do that what it does is
it infects an ant so spore gets into an
ant and it's or Bros its way in and it
starts to to branch out inside of the
ant and if you cut these poor ants open
they're like after a while they're just
pure fungus inside but they're still
alive and they look pretty normal
they're going around their business but
eventually when the fungus is ready they
get a signal and they get this urge to
climb upwards and what they do is they
climb up plants typically trees or small
bushes and they'll go about two feet up
and then they'll find a leaf and they
will go and they will perch on the
underside of the leaf usually amazingly
enough facing north by northwest these
ants there there there there heating
this this call that's coming from within
them to do this this very specific thing
and the reason they're doing that is
because it's good for the fungus so what
it does is it puts the fungus up in the
air above other ants and now the fungus
can get ready to spread what it does is
it produces a stock that pops out of the
ants head so this poor aunt has this
giant spike that grows up out of its
head that's covered in spores the fungus
meanwhile is is spreading out of the
ants legs and abdomen and is attaching
itself to the leaf so
so the antis is now being cemented to
the leaf and the fungus is also
hardening the exoskeleton of the ant in
a sense it's making this very durable
case this this this shelter kind of a
house where it can live and whether it
can survive and by being on the
underside of that leaf it's protected
from rain and it's protected from from
intense sunlight it's in this perfect
place for being a parasitic fungus and
now the spores from from the ant coming
out of that spike can shower down on the
ants below and infect them and make them
suffer that same horrible fate now
that's just one example I I know dozens
there probably hundreds of examples that
scientists have documented of parasites
manipulating the behavior of their hosts
sometimes it's going from one host to
another in the same species there are a
lot of cases where what the parasite
wants to do is get from one species to
another species so for example there is
a parasite called Toxoplasma it's very
common in birds and rats and so on lots
of mammals can carry it but they are not
the host where toxoplasma can really
reproduce to produce the next generation
of toxoplasma that host what's called
the final host is cat so you've got
types of plasma in something like a rat
for example and in order for it to
complete its life cycle it's got to get
into a cat rats are very good at not
getting into cats I mean that's sort of
what they're on earth for to avoid
getting eaten by cats they have
incredibly sensitive sense of smell and
if they get the faintest whiff of cat
odor they get very anxious and they look
around they take evasive action they
don't want to get eaten what's really
remarkable about a rat infected with
so plasma is that it looks totally
normal except that it's no longer afraid
of the smell of a cat in fact sometimes
when toxoplasma gets into rats actually
seem to get a little curious they say
this looks interesting i'm going to
investigate this and so it appears that
the Toxoplasma is is very precisely
manipulating the rat brain maybe by
secreting certain kinds of chemicals to
affect its whole network for processing
fear and other kinds of emotions and so
it may be making it an easier target for
cats what makes us really intriguing is
that about a quarter of all people on
earth are infected with toxoplasma we
get it from lots of different places so
for example the the soil is actually a
place where you can pick it up if a cat
has left its droppings in the area this
is why pregnant women are not supposed
to handle kitty litter because kitty
litter may be loaded with toxoplasma now
if you get infected with toxoplasma
generally it's not a big deal because
what happens is you may feel a little
fever but then after a while you recover
and you're fine what's happened is that
the Toxoplasma has formed little cysts
in your brain thousands and thousands
and thousands of cysts in your brain and
it's just hiding there it's just hanging
out it's still alive in fact every now
and then they might break out but your
immune system can sense that they've
broken out and they attack them again
and they go back into their cysts so
there's this balance that we strike the
reason that pregnant women aren't
supposed to handle a kitty litter is
because if the types of plasma gets into
their babies that's when the trouble
starts because the babies don't have a
mature immune system yet so there's
nothing there to keep toxoplasma in
check and so
replicate like crazy can cause brain
damage it's it's not a good thing yeah
so so there we are a billion people
maybe maybe two billion people with
toxoplasma in their brains and we know
that it can affect a mammal brains and
and the fact is that a rat brain and a
human brain aren't all that different in
the really basic ways they're quite
similar so is it possible that the
Toxoplasma is affecting people it's it's
possible the evidence is really I'd say
it's pretty sketchy at this point but
it's it's evidence that can't be just
dismissed out of hand so for example
people with toxoplasma have been
reported to get into more traffic
accidents so does this mean they're
being more reckless that they're not
being as anxious as a normal human or
rat might be I don't know the answer to
that but the fact remains that we have
these mind-altering parasites in our
brains and so I think we had to figure
out what they're doing
there are lots of diseases in the
tropics that we fortunately don't have
to contend with in places like the
United States and we should consider
ourselves fortunate because some of them
are really horrendous particularly
horrendous one is called sleeping
sickness sleeping sickness is caused by
a single-celled organism called the
trypanosome and it looks like a little
fluke or a kind of a flatworm under a
microscope but it's obviously much
tinier than that they are carried inside
certain kinds of flies in Africa and
these flies will bite people and they
will inject these parasites these
trypanosomes into these humans who would
then start to get sick and they do that
something called sleeping sickness which
you know not surprisingly makes you very
tired and rundown the real problem is
that unless you treated it is quite
fatal and so it's a serious problem in
particularly in the belt just below the
Sahara now a 100 years ago it was a
quite a serious problem I'm much more
serious than it is today but it's been
gradually eradicated from a lot of
places where it was a big problem it was
eradicated through good public health
through through treating people and
through trying to attack the population
of the Flies to basically break the
cycle of transmission and it's worked in
a lot of places and this is a story that
has been replicated with a number of
parasites with with for example a
parasite that caused this on the called
river blindness it's a worm that
actually like gets into your system and
can get into your eye and inflamed your
eye and scars it until you're blind
that's that is being very nicely
eradicated and other diseases well
sleeping sickness was with getting close
to that kind of
eradication or at least being really
driven down to very tiny levels but
unfortunately the war in Sudan has given
it a new lease on life and so there have
been in the past 10 or 20 years new
flare-ups of sleeping sickness and so
it's a real testament to the devastation
that war can have it isn't just people
being killed by bullets it's also people
killing being killed by parasites as
well